jour kader abderrahim merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur arte france
pas encore de réaction de paris il y en
aura-t-il selon vous on se souvient qu
emmanuel macron avait mis du temps à
féliciter abdelmajid tebboune lorsqu'il
avait été élu en décembre 2019 qu'elle
vient entretien des deux hommes
jusqu'à présent les liens a été plutôt
bon si j'en juge par les propos que
tenait le prénom de la république
emmanuel macron notamment dans une
interview qui restent dans les mémoires
en décembre 2019 dans laquelle il
affirmait qu'il apporterait tout son
soutien au président au gouvernement et
lui est visiblement il semblerait gpat
d'informations que le président mao et
été déçu et qu'il ait mis du temps à
accepter ou à réaliser l'idée et le
président est bonne vous n'avez pas des
marges de manoeuvre ou la latitude pour
pouvoir agir dans un processus de
rapprochement avec la porte puisqu'il ya
plusieurs perches qui ont été tendus à
l'algérie mais aucune d'entre elles n'a
été autant accepter par reprise par par
les autorités algériennes donc là on
atteint un point d'orgue on pensait que
la situation ne pouvait pas se dégrader
davantage mais on voit qu'il est encore
possible de faire pire mais ça accroît
l'isolément de l'algérie et de
présidents macro probablement va trouver
des partisans parce que nous sommes il a
dit tout haut ce que les chercheurs les
universitaires disent déjà depuis
plusieurs décennies à propos de ce
régime algérien de caciques algériens
qui sont des premiers à bénéficier des
visas et des avantages des passe droits
pour se rendre en france dans de bonnes
conditions
aujourd'hui ils sont que la fin de la
récréation réputé sifflet et qui va
falloir construire une monde relations
sur de nouvelles bases pour alger ce
sont les termes
système politico militaire au pouvoir et
discours qui repose sur une haine de la
france qui déplaisent notamment est ce
que paris met le doigt là où ça fait mal
ou à skis emmanuel macron est allé trop
loin ça va au-delà avec des matches de
très bonnes choses dans il ya aussi les
années bouteflika qui sont concernés
dans ces mots
oui oui je suis d'accord je pense que le
président maquereau a dit encore une
fois je le répète mais il a dit tout
c'est que nous sommes nombreux comme
chercheur universitaire à dire et à
écrire depuis plusieurs décennies
un régime qui réprime qui est pas prêt
ce qui n'a pas la compétence pour
permettre à son peuple simplement
d'accéder on l'a vu pendant la pandémie
ça peut péter accès aux eaux irako
mouvement de contestation populaire qui
a abouti on le rappelle à la chute à la
démission de d'abdelaziz bouteflika
oui c'est vrai que c'est aussi un appel
est là que je crois je crois que le
président macro ont dit en gros je fais
ma part il faut vous preniez vos
responsabilités il s'adresse aux
algériens et je crois que c'est un
message qui va être entendu il ya eu une
longue période pendant laquelle la fin
de bouteflika a été absolument
catastrophique pour l'algérie qui s'est
progressivement enfoncés dans un
isolement dont elle peine aujourd'hui à
sortir parce qu'elle n'y a pas de
nouveau projet un point valoir et
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter ce
geste diplomatique d'alger rappeler un
ambassadeur pour consultation qui suit
dans les relations paris alger on a vu
récemment la france faire la même chose
avec les etats-unis dans la crise des
sous-marins la confiance je cite mettra
du temps à être retrouvé c'est ce
qu'avait estimé un jean yves le drian le
chef de la diplomatie française
oui en effet ça ça va mettre du temps là
la relation entre la france et l'algérie
est singulière elle et elle est
différente les liens qui unissent les
deux pays sont quoi qu'il arrive
indestructible
je le veux le souligner parce que il
faut pas que l'on s'arrête à cette
péripétie
plot matic qui même si elle tend la
relation ne va pas la casser et ne va
pas l'annihiler mais encore une fois je
crois qu'il faut reconstruire une
nouvelle relation sur de nouvelles bases
quelles solutions selon vous pour sortir
de cette impasse diplomatique parce que
vous avez dit emmanuel macron va trouver
des partisans ça veut dire que à
l'échelle internationale il va y avoir
des personnes qui vont aller derrière
lui le soutenir pour pouvoir isoler
l'algérie ça veut dire que les temps
de du système politique actuel en
algérie sont sont comptés
je voudrais être d'accord avec vous mais
je crois que c'est allé un peu vite je
ne pense pas que ce sont ses paroles qui
vont abattre le régime ou le faire
tomber loin de là c'est un régime qui
est solidement enracinée dans le pays
qui bénéficie d'un appareil sécuritaire
militaire et de moyens de répression
contre sa population est contre toute
forme de contestation donc il ne
disparaîtra pas du jour au lendemain
mais l'idéal pour l'algérie et pour les
algériens c'est de construire ensemble
et avec ceux qui dirigent actuellement
évidemment une transition en douceur
pour éviter encore une fois la violence
que dont le pays a été meurtri dans les
années 90 je crois c'est la formule la
plus sage et qui me paraît être
aujourd'hui la plus réaliste pour éviter
les soubresauts que l'on a pu vivre et
connaître ailleurs dans le monde a je
pense ici à l'egypte à la tunisie et
dans des conditions sont beaucoup plus
tragique et normatif à la série mercy
kader abderrahim d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences à sciences po
directeur de recherche à l'épaisseur
situe prospective sécurité en europe
et auteur également d'une géopolitique
de l'algérie aux éditions bibliomonde
mai